[Music]
we are here today to consider the impact
of government spending on our economy
we're fortunate to have two world
renowned economists to offer their
testimony on a matter here we are
peace-out Great Recession thanks to me
as you see we're not in a depression
every destiny if you follow my lesson
Lord Keynes I am Nicolas be with reason
TV and today we're talking with Russ
Roberts a professor of economics at
George Mason University and the
co-creator of the fabulously successful
and hugely entertaining and I hate to
say edifying high Akane's rap videos you
just released the second one what's the
story of the second high Akane's rap
video we're focusing in on the role of
stimulus spending and we focus in
particularly the beginning on World War
two we only spent more too bad that only
happens when there's a world war you can
carve all you want about stats and
regression do you deny World War two cut
short the depression certainly this is
what you hear all the time the spending
effort from World War two ended the
Great Depression why is that wrong
Hayek's response is Wow one data point
you're jumping for joy
[Music]
ranges we use scarce resources for every
news pretty perverts to call back
prosperity rationed meat ration butter
the life of austerity Keynesian ideas
there's all this slack around so you can
just spend with no cost in fact we're
spending takes real resources out of the
economy in the u.s. there was a boom
after World War Two there was where does
that come from if not from you know what
kind of pent-up demand or you know that
the Keynesian magic got the gas tank
going I guess in that story because
again the forties in the early part of
the 40s it wasn't so good in England or
the United States or Germany how this
huge increase of government spending
that semi didn't stimulate a thing what
happened actually in the late years of
the war of 43 onward all the cans ian's
as we say in the song cry disaster get
the economy driving through bastards
they looked at the Keynesian multiplier
they saw government spending falling
dramatically which it did all these
unemployed workers how are they gonna
find jobs well they found jobs economy
did great and people say well well then
if it wasn't the war what was it I think
it was leaving things alone not a car we
don't need a mechanic put away the
wrenches the economy's organic I think
it's great in the video where you're
talking about like there aren't knobs
that you can turn up or down but
nowadays we're struggling with the after
effects or the continuing effects of
stimulus spending some people say look
if it wasn't for stimulus spending
things would have been far worse and
other people are saying and I think you
and I agree on this if we hadn't spent
that maybe we'd be out of the mess we're
in how you know is there a way to have a
definitive end to this battle or is it
really kind of two faiths clashes like
it's a lock word when you have really
smart Nobel prize-winning economists say
if we'd only spent two trillion instead
of close to 1 trillion we'd have been
fine by now others saying well we
should've spent a zero what does that
tell you tells you it's not science
that's the first thing it tells you it
tells you that despite 80 years of
trying to understand how the macro
economy works in the face of big
recessions and sometimes the depression
we don't really understand it and again
I think Hayek has the right thing to say
about this dispute which is in his 1974
Nobel prize-winning lecture the pretense
of knowledge
he says macroeconomics is not really
ever going to be solved
[Music]
the economy's not a classic and master
in college to think otherwise if the
pretense of knowledge iooks main
messages let's it's not even let things
alone but let's see a lot of different
ways of doing things can that ever
really be successful as a kind of mask a
guide to mass society you're right
there's a basic fundamental distrust of
leaving things alone and the person says
I can fix it always has an advantage
even if he's using the wrong tool to fix
what's broken so my hope is that things
like the Internet have given people an
appreciation of emergent order to solve
problems and I think Hayek's getting
these on the rise what's your hope for
the success of the video
the first one is millions of views the
sacrum went out to 200,000 views and
basically a day and it's gonna continue
to go upwards but you know what what's
success coming out of these videos well
a couple things one is my favorite
YouTube comment on the first one was
who's this Hayek guy why haven't I heard
of him so we're trying to get Hayek into
the debate we want him to have a place
at the table John and I are both Champa
polo the co-creator and I are just
extremely passionate about letting a
little voice for Liberty be her besides
the top-down approach of the keynesian
'he's the second goal is educational at
a different level one of the most
gratifying things we've had from the
first video is the schools they're using
it high schools and universities around
the world especially high schools
there's kids who are trying to get their
first taste of economics it's a
wonderful thing you've been at the
economics game for a long time you're
you're well known for being a really
strong narrative storyteller about
economics do you think economists are
getting better at kind of showing the
way that it actually affects humans as
opposed to economics being merely the
province of a bunch of supply and demand
diagrams well I think it's applying two
man diagrams would be great I think it's
more the things that makes it concerns
me more is it's the province of a bunch
of equations that are extremely extract
about all kinds of other stuff there's a
fight in the Academy and those of us who
like narrative and who like intuition
and who like the real world struggle a
competition against the quickly people
who say it's it's it's like physics but
we use different you know different
variables I don't think it's much like
physics at all I think the use of the
tools of physics is high I could point
out is scientism not science it gives
you the illusion you're doing science
which i think is worse than admitting
you don't know I would know what you're
doing
Russ Roberts co-creator of the latest
high Akane's video I want to thank you
for talking to us for recent TV
[Music]